[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 c'est parti pour le
sommaire de ce un magazine football on
ne ment pas jouer contre le mais ce
week-end en régionale 3 et les promus
mort d'asia l'ont emporté 3-2 avec une
superbe prestation de leur gardien
antoine baptiste coup de projecteur ans
au magazine
cyclisme le cinquième grand prix de
montigny le bretonneux s'est tenue ce
dimanche dans la commune
une cinquantaine de coureurs à
participer à ce rendez-vous reportage à
suivre
course à pied sidy diallo un marathonien
de monti le bretonneux va organiser son
propre eco trail la compétition qui
relie 50 ans li bin à paris a été annulé
à cause du comique 19 nous le recevrons
dans ce magazine l'actualité sportive
c'est maintenant sur tv à 78
[Musique]
on commence par du football dans le
championnat de régionale 3 maurepas
confirme son bon début de saison par une
deuxième victoire en deux matches
disputés les morgues bazire l'ont
emporté 3 2 face à lemé grâce notamment
à une belle prestation de leur gardien
des images de nicolas nombre et les
morts pas bien peuvent laisser éclater
leur joie ils viennent d'engranger leur
deuxième victoire en deux matches dans
le championnat de r3 pourtant rien n'a
été simple pour le produit dans cette
rencontre
bousculés à deux partout ils prennent
les devants avec ce troisième but sur ce
penalty 3-2 à cinq minutes de la fin à
maurepas conseils à son tour un penalty
mais le gardien antoine baptiste surgit
pour sauver son équipe
score final 3 à 2 le tireur freddy
ralenti sa course
je pense qu'il a essayé de demain dit
fier de moi durant d'erreurs mais après
je pars du bon côté j'ai la chance de
sortir il est pas très très bien tiré
mais j'ai la chance de sortir le cas
c'est cool on a un grand antoine qui
nous sort le penalty
même si ça arrive sur les 10-15
dernières secondes voire vraiment la fin
du match mais ça a fait ça fait un grand
bien à l'équipe et ça nous a permis
d'aller chercher ensuite la victoire
cette deuxième victoire de la saison
propulse eu les mots repasser en tête du
classement de cette poule d avec 6
points surtout sept buts marqués en deux
matches
l'objectif de base c'est comme toute
l'équipe qui monte c'est le maintien
maintenant on se refuse à rien
on a fait deux matches deux victoires si
on peut aller chercher au moins le haut
de tableau la première partie de tableau
ça sera déjà bien
mais voilà je fais pas pas vous dire
qu'on veut monter mais si ça se présente
pourquoi pas pour continuer à croire à
une place dans le haut du classement
maurepas ira défier le dimanche 11
octobre l'équipe 2 de versailles
objectif réaliser un trois sur trois en
ce début de championnat
on continue à parler football en
nationale 2 un week end noir pour les
a's yvelinois versailles s'est incliné 2
1 sur le terrain de saint malo et poissy
a perdu 2 à 0 sur son terrain contre
vannes au classement ça va mal poissy
bon dernier du championnat avec
seulement 2 points depuis le début de la
saison
versailles de son côté et 14e sur 16
dans le championnat de nationale 3 le fc
mantois n'a pu faire mieux que 0 à 0
face au blanc mesnil à domicile
un résultat qui n'arrange pas forcément
les yvelinois elles sont à l'heure
actuelle ne vienne du classement avec
une seule victoire depuis le début du
championnat en dire de district le
championnat reprenait ce week-end pour
cette première journée le suspense était
au rendez vous sartrouville s'impose
contre boyard 6-3 deux voisins gagne 3 0
face à carey l'aggresion où il perd 2 à
1 contre aubergenville 2 à 1 pour
gargenville fasse avaler 78 bûcher
l'oise epône se neutralisent 0-0 enfin
bailly perd 3,1 sur son teint contre le
chesnay le leader à l'issue de cette
première journée et voisins le
bretonneux
on continue à parler à football jean
claude blanc le directeur général
délégué du paris saint germain est venu
mardi dernier dans les yvelines à
versailles pour signer une convention
environnementale concerne le futur
centre d'entraînement du psg à poissy
vous le savez le club de la capitale va
quitter d'ici 2023 le camp des loges à
saint-germain-en-laye
nous en avons profité pour lui poser
trois questions sur ce futur complexe
c'est notre interview express
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les travaux ont démarré puisque c'est
aujourd'hui certainement un des plus
gros sites de travaux pour la
préparation la préparation des sols tout
ce qui est la préparation avant la
construction et donc il ya énormément de
machines qui sont sur le site à poissy
pour créer les trois grandes plateformes
sur lequel nous viendrons construire le
centre de formation pour les jeunes et
le centre d'entraînement pour les
professionnels et donc les construction
des bâtiments eux-mêmes devraient
démarrer dans le courant de l'année 2021
pour s'achever au début de l'année 2000
on va rassembler sur un même site des
équipes des plus jeunes dès dès le plus
jeune âge des les neuf ans jusqu'aux
professionnels on va rassembler sur un
même site l'ensemble des professionnels
et des jeunes qui va nous permettre au
club de de détecter de deux portes et de
développer les talents
régionaux des yvelines mais au delà de
la région parisienne pour les faire
grandir
et puis lors leur donner un un coup de
d'aspiration pour leur donner envie
d'aller s'entraîner aussi à terme sur
les terrains des pros il est important
comme dans tous les grands clubs
européens pour doter le paris
saint-germain d'infrastructures qui
permettent de de s'entraîner dans
l'excellence de faire progresser les
jeunes de créer cette mécanique
aspirationnel et donc à terme d'avoir
dans l'équipe de plus en plus de jeunes
qu'ils sont innés qui seront in et de la
formation du paris saint germain
on continue par de la boxe après un an
sans être remonté sur le ring tony yoka
le boxeur de 28 ans originaires de
chanteloup les vignes s'est facilement
imposé contre johann duhaupas ce
vendredi à paris le champion olympiques
2016 a dominé son adversaire en un peu
plus d'une minute dès la première
reprise
les viennois est toujours invaincu en
huit combats dont 7 avant la limite il
vise dans les prochaines années
un titre mondial handball plusieurs
matchs ont été annulés ce week-end à
cause du kobe de 19 dans les yvelines
mais la rencontre entre le ch est né à
abbeville s'est bien tenu les deux
équipes se sont séparées sur un match
nul 27 partout avec six buts d'anthony
borelli avec ce résultat le club se
retrouve en milieu de classement
il y avait également du cyclisme ce
week-end dans les yvelines la cinquième
édition du grand prix cycliste de
montigny était organisée ce dimanche
matin dans la commune une cinquantaine
de coureurs à participer à ce rendez
vous des images de justin brazy le vent
et la pluie ne les ont pas découragés
une cinquantaine de cyclistes au lieu
des 150 inscrits est venu ce dimanche 27
septembre sur la ligne de départ pour
participer au 5e grand prix cycliste de
montigny et l'épreuve prévue
initialement au printemps cette journée
est une journée
id non prévus pour en plus remercier les
courageux qui sont enlevés ce matin
de bonne heure pour venir faire une
course sous la pluie et dans le vent
mais c'est un peu parti de fait partie
du métier de coureur cycliste
les coureurs de 18 à 50 ans ont réalisé
26 tours de 3 km pour un total de 78 km
à la fin de l'épreuve les organisateurs
avaient bloqué plusieurs rues de
montigny le bretonneux pour créer un
parcours atypique pour les sportifs sont
larges
on sait relativement plat et la grosse
difficulté c'est la montée de nicolas à
bout
suivant le sens du vent s'ils vont
pousser coureurs c'est facile s'il est
dans l'otan c'est difficile cette
édition 2020 a permis à un coureur de
monti le bretonneux de s'illustrer
romain bardet homonyme du célèbre
coureur français devenu le premier
sportif du club a remporté ce grand prix
une nouvelle édition sera programmée
l'année prochaine les organisateurs
espèrent cette fois ci l'organiser au
printemps on continue cette émission par
du basket une nouvelle saison a débuté
pour le fc trappes après deux matches
l'équipe affiche un bilan de deux
victoires les trappistes se sont imposés
75 à 65 face à fécampoise pour nous en
parler avec nous en plateau le président
du club jacques michel et le capitaine
de l'équipe michael mon congo bonsoir
messieurs bonsoir
tout d'abord je remercie le nonce au
verso de tout ça à plaisir de vous
recevoir à laroque son sentiment après
cette rencontre
cette victoire de ce week-end alors
c'est un bon sentiment parce que tout en
sachant que ça peut être facile la
préparation de la saison avec la
situation qu vide aujourd'hui on a un
bilan positif
cc c'est bien même si on sait que on a
encore du travail à faire mais un
sentiment positif après la victoire
contre fécamp qu'est ce qui a fonctionné
en sept rencontres
la diversité dans notre jeu c'est à dire
qu'on a pu mettre la balle à l'intérieur
on a pu trouver les extérieurs
on a eu assez de variété dans notre jeu
après on a pêché un peu en deuxième
mi-temps en terme de rotations parce
qu'il nous manque encore des joueurs
américains notamment qui doit arriver
spencer vont avec la situation qu vide
c'est un peu difficile de le faire venir
mais voilà on essaie de continuer avec
les éléments qu'on a aujourd'hui
président est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est le début de saison idéal pour
votre équipe
en termes de résultats c'est tout à fait
le début idéal maintenant en termes
sportifs comme mike vient de le dire
c'est pas tout à fait l'idéal je dirais
même que
en tant que président je suis inquiet
sur sur l'avenir de la saison on espère
que ça se passera bien
nous sommes nous préparés d'une manière
quasiment idéale puisque c'est
certainement le meilleur début de saison
de situation du club depuis dix ans
parce que cette vidéo justement
eh bien d'abord une chose nous sommes
dégagées des difficultés financières que
nous avions que nous traînions depuis
depuis dix ans et nous sommes heureux
avec le trésorier d'avoir réussi à
redresser cette situation dont nous
avions hérité et comme nous sommes
sommes dégagées on sait aussi dégager
d'un règlement judiciaire qui nous a
faut dire pourrit la vie durant la
dernière saison alors que nous n'avions
aucune situation de règlement judiciaire
à subir notre notre comment
et hassen a été retenue par la justice
et maintenant eh bien nous sommes
complètement disponible pour faire du
sport et pour développer le club
ce que nous espérions depuis quelque
temps déjà donc on est paradoxalement
malgré la crise que vides et bien en
situation nous favorable c'est vrai et
il faut dire aussi que nous avons appris
dans ses difficultés bien à faire face
ces difficultés ce qui explique que par
exemple la saison dernière qui a été
interrompue et bien n'a pas empêché
l'ensemble de l'équipe de marquer leur
fidélité au club c'est tout à fait
remarquable
justement on va revenir sur ce début de
saison sur le plan sportif
est ce que vous attendiez à avoir un
résultat de 2 victoires en 2 matchs
alors pour être honnête avec vous comme
le sait toujours dans le sport tout le
monde a envie de gagner tout de suite
mais ce qui est important c'est de
travailler dans la durabilité
alors on a un effectif qui est depuis là
depuis l'année dernière on a appris
ensemble on a travaillé ensemble
donc ça nous a apporté de l'expérience
et c'est vrai que je pense que cette
année on a un petit avantage sur les
autres équipes parce qu'il ya un noyau
une ossature de l'équipe de l'année
dernière qui est revenu on essaie de la
renforcer avec certains joueurs qui
doivent encore arriver et je pense que
ça va nous aider sur le long terme par
rapport à la saison
après bien évidemment une saison les
langues il faut un peu de chance il faut
aussi que les joueurs sont en bonne
santé il faut qu'à une bonne osmose
il faut travailler sur l'ensemble de la
saison et bien analyser les matchs avec
les vidéos qu'on peut faire et que les
entraîneurs et perfectionner les joueurs
aussi chaque jour donc voilà on va
s'atteler sur cela pour essayer de de
faire une saison qui est vraiment solide
et viser la montée parce que c'est
c'est l'objectif du club la montée cette
année la montée cette année président
c'est bien seul objectif c'était d'être
notre viser la dernière qui a été
interrompue c'est bien sûr notre
objectif cette année puisque comme le
disait m tout de suite
eh bien on a une équipe qui est qui
devrait être fin qui est déjà excellente
par rapport à l'année dernière mais qui
devrait être plus forte si on arrive à
avoir les éléments qui sont prévues vous
êtes vraiment je n'en sais rien parce
que les difficultés avec des états unis
tant du côté étasunien que du côté de
l'état français
c'est pas facile et je dois dire que
l'état français ne nous rassure pas du
tout
actuellement nous sommes vraiment très
préoccupés en tant que président de club
des hauts-de-seine et nous on vient
d'avoir samedi la nôtre l'assemblée
générale du basket de l'île de france
oui les présidents de club en général
sont très préoccupés par la situation
qui est faite aux sports alors sur le
plan sportif l'équipe ces dernières
années joue très défensif avec un gros
bloc qui a qui récupère des ballons
notamment au bond est ce que ce sera la
même philosophie de jeu cette année ou
pas pour l'équipe de trappes
alors nous on essaie d'avoir un voulait
avoir un jeu plus offensif j'attendais
beaucoup plus complet parce que bon
c'est que
face à une équipe qui prend beaucoup de
points n'ont pas beaucoup pas beaucoup
c'est vrai mais quand on dit c'est la
défense qui gagnent les championnats
donc on essaie d'avoir une bonne
solidité défensive d'assurer les robots
doués spencer l'amérique en attente pour
qu'il arrive parce que il n'aura kate
c'est super importante et après ensuite
développé un jeu de transition si c'est
possible si après c'est pas possible on
a le jeu demi terrain où voilà c'est ma
responsabilité en tant que meneur de jeu
de poser le jeu et de gérer les
possessions parce qu'au basket ball il
faut savoir que les possessions c'est
important chaque possession à la
importante c'est un jeu de miss match
c'est à dire que c'est un jeu de
davantage savoir là où on a des
opportunités pour pouvoir trouver des
paniers faciles et mettre nos coquilles
puis en avant et voilà c'est le rôle de
l'entraîneur et moi qui suis mineur
pourra gérer tout ça donc voilà un jeu
complet en tout cas qu'on essaie de
pratiquer cette dernière question
ce sera le derby ce week-end contre le
chesnay versailles
c'est forcément un match particulier que
comme chaque année
comment vous l'appréhendez cette
rencontre ça m'a pris beaucoup de
plaisir beaucoup de plaisir parce qu'on
sait que l'année dernière les a déjà
battus chez eux
et forcément à cette année ils vont
avoir un esprit revanchard et donc voilà
on espère qu'on va voir la salle pleine
pour nous comme au premier match à la
maison contre le bihorel donc voilà on
invite des supporters ce soit vraiment à
venir nombreux nous supporter parce que
c'est un match qui est important c'est
que le ch est né il joue aussi la montée
comme nous donc
donc voila nous on va on va l'aborder
sans son pression et essayer de faire le
maximum à domicile pour condamner ce
match merci à vous deux dépassé sur ce
plateau bon courage pour la suite du
championnat la prochaine rencontre de
trappes contre est donc programmé contre
le chesnay
ce samedi soir à 20 heures au gymnase
paul mallet deux trappes en prend
maintenant la direction de
saint-germain-en-laye une première
mondiale s'est déroulée à dans la ville
l'ultra trail heure fabrice pancrazi a
réalisé sur trois jours une course de 45
heures sur un tapis roulant à l'occasion
de la virade des rois à l'événement pour
vaincre la mucoviscidose au total ce
spécialiste des longues courses a
parcouru 160 kilomètres avec 10000
mètres de dénivelé on écoute justement
l'ultra trail heures au micro de justin
brazy je vous avoue je suis totalement
épuisé
j'ai dormi une heure la nuit dernière
avant-hier et 2h cette nuit et je
dormais dans ma voiture qui est juste en
face donc je suis totalement épuisé et
puis il ya l'effort physique qui est
extrêmement difficile puisque sur un
tapis on fait toujours le même geste
ça veut donc dire que ce sont toujours
les mêmes muscles qui travaille et je
suis pétri de tendinites
donc en plus il a fallu gérer la
souffrance liée à la douleur de ses
tendinites
en tennis après le double arthur
rinderknecht dispute pour la première
fois cette dernière roland garros en
simple le joueur originaire de 25 ans
formé à saint germain en laye et au
comité les yvelines de feucherolles joue
en ce moment même porte d'auteuil le
163e joueur mondial affronte ce lundi au
premier tour le slovène aljaz bedene 55e
joueur mondial
avec son mètre 95 il espère lui poser à
quelques problèmes et passer ce premier
tour
au moment de cet enregistrement le score
est de 6 2 1 0 pour le slovène
on ouvre maintenant une page rugby fait
plaisir a remporté sa première victoire
de la saison en fédérale 2 ce week-end
les pzero a longtemps porté 20 à 16 face
au rugby club de courbevoie ce résultat
permet aux yvelinois de remonter au
classement et de pointer à la septième
place avec six points au compteur
dans la poule 2 de fédérale 3 versailles
réussi à engranger une troisième
victoire en trois matches les versets se
sont imposés 29 à 12 face à compiègne on
a ce dimanche avec 13 points en trois
journées les joueurs de la cité royale
sont premiers du classement devant
l'aide se tournant deux équipes qui
s'affronteront le 10 octobre prochain à
quelques centaines de mètres du terrain
de rugby de versailles à porsche
fontaine ce dimanche 27 septembre la
ville a donné le nom de jean-marc
fennell au centre sportif qui abrite
notamment l'athlétisme le très regretté
adjoint au maire délégué aux sports et
aux ressources humaines entre 2008 et
2020 est décédé le 10 mai dernier du
colis 19 il était également président de
la course paris versailles depuis 1989
cette inauguration a s'est d'ailleurs
tenue le jour de la 43e édition annulée
en raison des contraintes sanitaires on
écoute les réactions au micro de justin
brasier tout le monde pense que la
mémoire des gens marque devaient
continuer
dans un lieu sportif il était l'homme du
paris versailles était président du
paris versailles depuis presque trente
ans lui-même ancien sportif il s'était
investi dans d'autres domaines
mais c'est eux mêmes le sport qui était
sa marque personnelle ça soit les amis
les intervenants des gens de la ville
s'est tous réunis voilà pour rendre un
dernier hommage à jean marc qu'à mon
père puis voilà c'est dans ces moments
un peu compliqué et on sait que les
années qui suivent
au moment de paris versailles sera
toujours compliqué l'ensemble de la
famille
direction maintenant les terrains de
golf depuis le 4 septembre et jusqu'au
18 octobre les golf blue green ouvrent
leurs portes aux débutants des
initiations à gratuites sont proposées
pour donner à les premières bases ou aux
novices une opportunité pour le golf de
guerville qui vient tout juste de
rouvrir son parcours 18 trous un
reportage de bixente mérian santisteban
une heure entière de jeux gratuits c'est
la formule proposée par le golf de
guerville dans le cadre d'initiation de
quoi apprendre les bases ont fait le
mouvement de balancier en essayant de se
relâcher
ça va demander une certaine coordination
et un relâchement du corps pour arriver
à rendre le corps disponible à l'essai
le mouvement vraiment naturel se faire
c'est pas difficile five effectivement
comme ils le disent à se relâcher parce
qu'on est complètement figé sur le club
un court placée sous le signe de la
bonne humeur qui donne envie à certains
d'aller plus loin
c'est toujours les parcours aussi très
jolie donc c'est pour ça que je me mette
au golf je trouve ça sympa je pense que
par thibault a adhéré et à croquer et
continuent d'attendre le but c'est de
rendre le golf accessible à tous et à
toutes
que ce soit plus fun et tout en en
gardant un esprit soit familiale soit
amical une opportunité pour le golf de
guerville qui vient de rouvrir ses 18
trous après deux ans de travaux de
rénovation en a pas l'exploitation de
quatre trous du coup qu'on a reconstruit
si les travaux ont duré à peu près un an
il ya eu un temps de réflexion pour ça
où et comment les construire sur le sur
le terrain à les trous sont ouverts
depuis lundi dernier on arrive
le 21 à tout le public l'architecte a
voulu conserver l'esprit qui avait
auparavant c'est à dire d'être ou plutôt
étroit au début est large à l'arrivée
objectif du golf de guerville et gagner
une centaine d'abonnés d'ici un an dont
une trentaine ayant débuté par
l'initiation gratuite dans cet agenda
nous allons parler course à pied vous
l'avez sûrement entendu l'eco trail de
paris est annulé cette année après avoir
été déplacés dans le calendrier au 3
octobre à cause du coc vide 19 la course
a été définitivement annulée mais un
yvelinois veux courir sceptiques au
trail il a notamment créé un événement
pour réaliser l'eco trail le 3 octobre
prochain
cet homme c'est ligne mantes 1 à sidy
diallo bonsoir bonsoir
alors si diallo pourquoi vous voulez
créer cet événement ben je voulais créer
ce pour encourager d'autres coureurs à
part à courir quand même puisque nous
pouvons le faire
les mesures de kobe ne nous empêche pas
de courir de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
de l'île des loisirs jusqu'à paris et
même au delà
les calculs sont annulés beaucoup de
gens en fait c'est ce et de courage
alors que la course à pied moi je
je lui dis je le répète c'est une
activité naturelle des humains et ça
nous permet aussi d'être en meilleure
santé de voir un gros système
immunitaire je pense que j'essaie de
donner l'exemple
je puis 250 donc normalement 1
je suis considéré comme vu mon âge comme
personnes fragiles face à la cohue vide
alors que là aujourd'hui je viens de
faire un marathon je suis parti de de
montigny je suis allé jusqu'à paris
bercy au ministère des finances
je suis revenu pour terminer le marathon
devant la tour eiffel 42 2 km et vous
voyez je suis pas je parlais très
fatigué c'était juste avant l'émission
c'est voilà c'est juste juste à voir
avant l'émission
en fait je devais à la panique à
boulogne et puis je me suis dit bah je
vais là pied je vais courir j'ai plus
mon sac mon sac de trail voilà disons
qu'aujourd'hui je j'ai fait d'une
certaine manière le trail l'eco trail de
paris mais j'ai pris un raccourci
parce que l'eco trail 80km cultu part de
l'île des loisirs
donc ces quatre corps et kilomètres la
plage en effet que 42 j'ai pris un
raccourci et quel sera le parcours
justement le 3 octobre
moi je suis pour organisateurs des
courses en fait c'est juste
j'ai créé l'idée c'est pour motiver les
gens chacun vient il
chacun si les personnes qui viendront
seront indépendants chacun décide
la distance la distance qu'il ou elle
fait le parcours aussi donc à ce qui me
concerne je ferai un tube relax je peux
lui de faire un tour du lac ensuite
continuez sur le parcours de l'eco trail
de paris jusqu à buc et a vu qu ils
jouent le jeu à versailles par la forêt
et de là bas je pense aller jusqu'à la
tour eiffel est peut-être un peu au delà
pour faire 42 km vous avez parlé que les
organisateurs ou pas du tout de votre
initiative
non non parce que ils ont annulé donc
par contre mon événement je me sur la
page facebook de l'organisation mais ça
n'a pas l'air d'intéresser beaucoup de
couleurs parce que je dois je vais vous
poser la question est-ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de personnes intéressées pour
l'instant moi ce que je vois je suite à
l'annulation la lance de l'innovation
surfer sur facebook
alors j'ai vu beaucoup de réactions gens
sont plutôt contents a bien comme ça a
coûté on voit courir en 2021 ou
peut-être un 2022 comme ça je le temps
de me préparer je n'ai vu personne qui
dit bah je vais courir donc je ne fais
pas beaucoup d'illusions mais j'espère
quand même c'est pas pour moi puisque
moi je le fais tout seul samedi moi je
le ferai avec mon épouse 1 un de mes
fils qui rompt avec moi peut-être
jusqu'à versailles au moins jusqu'à
versailles c'est juste pour motiver les
autres pour dire les gars c'est pas le
monde et le décourager toutes les
courses quasiment toutes les courses à
pied sont annulés je suis pas pourquoi
puisqu'il ya d'autres d'autres activités
sportives qui se pa annulée si on attend
de course confirmé on risque d'attendre
longtemps alors que chacun peut se
transformer en son organisateur de
courses directeur de course avec avec
les applications qu'on a et les montres
gps on peut faire le parcours est
ensuite une fois une fois c'est sur
ordinateur on voit un parcours avec les
kilomètres c'est très beau on l'a fait
on n'a pas besoin nécessairement de
médailles en tout cas je pense faut pas
trop attendre maintenant les courses
parce que sinon ça culoz et puis il ya
des gens voilà qui vont du mauvais côté
des leçons comment on fait pour vous
rejoindre sur votre événement alors
l'événement ça s'appelle le le le
elle yvelines paris 2020 si facebook
donc le trait yvelines paris sur
facebook s'inscrit et on revient et on
vient on peut faire juste un tour du lac
c'est bien douce le tour du lac ou bien
aller jusqu'à la gare de 50 ans
continuez jusqu'à versailles à chaville
viroflay il ya le temps pour revenir
donc on est libre de le faire et
j'espère que vous viendrez malgré les
prévisions météo qui sont pas très
bonnes
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
si diallo votre eco trail est programmée
le 3 octobre prochain à partir de 11h du
matin enfin on se quitte passé à images
le variétés club de france et ses
anciennes gloires du football français
était à ce samedi à la celle saint cloud
pour un match amical d'exhibition les
variétés affronter une équipe hybride
entre l'association sos gazelle et
l'équipe locale de la ville aux
résultats 800 appels 8 à 0 pour le
variété pour son 2360 cinquième match
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tb 78
[Musique]